And the 1970s and eighties over 100 families in California had the homes
ransacked by the same man.
Many of them woke up in the middle of the night to a flashlight,
blinding their eyes.
A man was standing over their bed wearing a black ski mask.
He Hell's knives to their throats and guns to their heads,
demanding that they do what he said if they wanted to live within a matter of
hours,
he ruins and ended vives slipping small mementos into his pocket.
As he ran into the darkness,
51 women were raped in their own beds sometimes while the husbands and children
watched,
he met had 12 people that we know all of this,
the kill counts maybe higher.
He traveled throughout California targeting homes.
Wherever he went,
he changed his style of killing ans left misleading clues to throw off the
police.
Unlike most serial killers,
there was no connection between the victims and virtually no way of predicting
where he would strike next.
The survivors trying to move on with our lives,
but many of them received phone calls years after the attacks hearing a
threatening whisper.
On the other line.
Remember when we played in 1986 the killings mysteriously stops and the trail it
just ran Kohl's for decades.
The serial killer was on the loose.
The police calls him the east area rapist or the ear for short.
He has also been called the original night stalker for years.
The true identity of the Ia was an unsolved mystery.
There's no one in California could forget.
For 44 years straight,
the Sacramento County Police Department received phone calls from people who
believed that they had information about the air,
and yet none of those suspects ever panned out.
A freelance writer names Michelle Mcnamara again,
the unions have this cold case.
In 2006 she began a blog and a podcast called true crime diary and Shanta clues
with a community of online web sleuths who are equally as passionate about
getting the ear behind bars.
In 2013 she wrote an article about the East area rapist in Los Angeles magazine
calls in the footsteps of a killer.
She gave this murderer a more fitting nickname,
the golden state killer.
She began writing a book calls,
I'll be gone in the dark where she interviewed detectives and compiled
information across various jurisdictions that had never been pieced together
before.
She has an investigator from the Contra Costa County police departments named
Paul Holes and together they shared theories and information on how to
potentially catch the killer.
In 2016 Michelle Mcnamara suddenly passed away in her sleep,
but before she died she told her husband that the one thing she wanted was for
the golden state killer to get caught.
It didn't matter to her if she was the one to do it.
After taking time to grieve her husband's Patton Oswald hired helps her
posthumously,
published her book.
It was finished in February of 2018 one of the many leads,
Paul holds disgust with Mcnamara before she died,
was the potential of DNA evidence found on new genealogy.
Web zines like 23 and me holds,
took the DNA from old rape kits and ran it through an online genealogy database.
While they got him matched to a first cousin together with a task force,
they were able to gather enough evidence.
Defines the man who matched the DNA.
In April of 2018 the police raided the home of Joseph James to Angelo.
While we do not know the intimate details about his private life,
it would seem that Joseph James to Angela had a fairly normal childhood.
He was born in 1945 and bath New York.
His father also name's Joseph to Angelo was a celebrated pilots in the air force
during World War Two.
His mother,
Kathleen Grote,
was a waitress at a Denny's.
His parents would they to divorce.
Kathleen married her second husband and they moved out to California.
There was a piece of paper found at one of the crime scenes that may give some
insight into his childhood.
The paper had been named the homework evidence and it reads like a journal
entry,
not as the weld the weld.
That reminds me of the sixth grade.
I hated that.
Yeah.
Did Angelo goes on to write it down to his teacher who punished him for talking
in class by forcing him to write the same sentence,
50 to 150 times.
There's a homework assignment.
I never hated anyone.
As much as I hated him.
He describes it spending hours on this homework and wrote,
it wasn't fair to make me suffer like that.
I cried because I was ashamed.
I will be ashamed of my sixth grade.
Yeah,
forever.
Some people believe that the story of the sixth grade may have been a lie.
It could have been a red herring to confuse the police about his motives for a
crime or it could be that he truly does see himself as a victim and he sees the
sixth grade is the turning point in his life.
When he began to harbor a deep hatred for people,
you attended Folsom high school,
then Sacramento,
and then California State University in Sacramento to earn a degree in criminal
justice.
He joins the navy after graduation and he served in the Vietnam war in the late
sixties he was engaged to a young woman named Bonnie Colwell,
who worked as a lab assistant at Sierra College.
Bonnie calls off the engagement since it broke to Angelo's heart.
We may never know what happens behind closed doors,
but according to her brother,
she had plenty of good reasons for dumping him.
Just like the shame and anger he harbored towards the sixth grade teacher.
He never let go of this betrayal.
Years later,
victims would hear him sobbing.
I hate you,
Bonnie.
I hate you.
Over and over again.
In 1973 Joseph James to Angela,
I married a woman named Sharon Marie Huddle Mans.
They would go on to have three daughters together.
In 1974 he graduated from the police academy and it became an officer or
endeavor,
Celia,
California.
The next year in 1975 a police officer was shot by a criminal known for years as
the Visalia ran Sacca.
Who has now been identified is Joseph James.
Angela.
In 1976 he transferred to the Orban Police Department.
He was caught stealing account of dog repellent and sends a Hannah from a
grocery store.
These items.
Clearly it should have been a red flag,
but he was up to more than shoplifting,
but the police fired him and they didn't look into it any further.
After being fired from his job to Angelo,
threatened to kill the police.
Chief Nick [inaudible].
A few days after the ink threatens the police chief's daughter ran into his room
in the middle of the night saying that she saw a man in a mosque outside shining
a flashlight into a bedroom.
When the chief went outside to check,
he saw shoe impressions at his daughter's window.
Okay.
First recorded victim was a ransacking and Visalia,
California in 1974 after to Angelo joined the police force.
In the beginning,
he was sloppy.
He didn't wear a mask and witnesses were able to describe his face to the
police.
He was 29 years old at the time,
but he looked young for his age and many people believe the rand sacco was in
his teens or early twenties but he would not begin to kill people until it was
in his thirties according to a crime writer Billy Jensen,
he has spoken to victims.
He believed Joseph James to Angelo attempted to murder them long before 1974 and
as the police sun cover new evidence about him,
it may reveal a much darker youth.
Back in the 1970s and 80s various police jurisdictions did not communicate with
one another when it came to their crimes does.
Angela would have known this fact firsthand and he took advantage of this.
After convincing a few crimes in one county,
he would simply move on to the next one,
often nearly being caught as a soccer.
He went to great lengths to prevent being seen and began wearing a black ski
mask.
He also planned out strategies for each of his crimes.
Police sketch isn't physical descriptions were released.
It looks almost identical to his true face,
so he lost a huge amount of waste in order to change his appearance.
He targeted one story homes with similar layouts,
which made it easier for him to tell how many people were in the house.
He'd drive around neighborhoods and sketched out maps to help him find his way
at night.
After breaking into someone's house,
he went to search through the victim's Pason.
Look for her driver's license.
When he approached them in their bedrooms,
he would whisper their names,
which made them wonder if he actually knew them in their personal lives.
He would also take notice of their hobbies and make up a story of where he knew
them from.
People know now,
but he chose his victims at random and he was purposefully leaving false
breadcrumbs for them to follow.
For example,
one married couple has a boat in their driveway,
so he said,
I saw you at the lake.
Other times he would give the victims false information about himself,
like don't tell the pigs about my van outside.
He didn't have a van.
In fact,
it was transportation of choice was bicycles that he would steal from open
guarantor's and later dump as he ran.
This way,
no one could identify is real vehicle and to report it to the police.
But the fact that he always calls police officer's pigs with all say misleading
since he was a cop himself,
after years of targeting women who were home alone,
raise the stakes higher.
We've done two couples.
He would come prepared with [inaudible] shoe laces.
So he could force the husband to lay on his stomach and tie his hands and then
put a stack of plates on the man's back.
If the husband's moved,
he said he would hear the crashing plates and he would kill the wife
immediately.
The husband has a lever helpless while he heard his wife being sexually
assaulted to Angelo switched up the weapons he used in each breaking.
Sometimes it was a knife.
Sometimes it was a gun.
In one case,
he even beat someone to death with a log from the fireplace.
The only comment thread he could not run away from this his own body.
Each of his rape victims described him as having an extremely small penis.
This would become a detail that investigators would take very seriously.
They asked local doctors if they could identify patients with a micro penis and
ruled out potential suspects if they were to well in doubt.
He wants a psychological Cedar's too got off on instilling fear into the hearts
of human beings.
One of the many tricks he used to avoid capture was waiting in the house long
after committing the rape one victim in Sacramento.
They dinner badge after being assaulted for several minutes.
Her young daughter had been laying in bed next to her the entire time and when
the mother and asked her daughter if she was okay,
the little girl whispered money.
He was still standing in the bedroom hiding in the darkness.
As soon as she spoke,
he moved toward and pushed it down on the bed next to our house.
He would then leave silently while there's victims remained frozen on the bed in
fear.
This gave him hours to escape before the police were called months or even years
after being raped.
[inaudible] Angelo with coolers,
victims to taught them on Christmas Day,
threatening to come back and finish the job.
Any of it's fine being victims today.
PTSD.
According to Carol daily,
a woman who works for the Sacramento County Police Department in the 1970s they
held a town hall meeting.
Do you discuss the East area rapist?
People were understandably terrified.
This was years before proper security systems were invented.
Over 6,000 guns were sold in a month.
People were hiring.
Locksmiths do add deadbolts to their doors.
As many people bought guard dogs.
To keep them safe.
During the town hall meetings to discuss the year a man stood up in the crowds
and his claims that he did not believe that the air was real because he could
not fathom that any man would allow his wife to be raped while he was home.
A few months later,
not the same man and his wife became victims,
offers a Carol daily was shaken to the core.
She knew that whoever the air was,
he had been at the meeting that night.
It's probably relishing in the fear that he brought to those people.
The Devil was hiding in plain sight.
Yeah.
Since he could no longer work as a police officer,
Joseph to Angela became a big rig truck mechanics,
but a grocery chain called Save Mart.
According to one of his coworkers to Angela was always on his best behavior and
it's acted like he was afraid of getting in trouble.
He was never late to work.
You never called in sick secretly.
He continued his crimes at night,
only stopping in the year 1986 no one knows yet why he chose that year to stop
his killing spree,
except that it was the same year that his youngest daughter was born.
It's possible that he reached a point where he simply could no longer continue
to live a double life and keep it secret from his family,
or perhaps he continued his crimes under a completely different emo at home.
They had a reputation for being an angry and violent man.
People in the neighborhood,
the voids and interacting with him,
and he never made any friends.
He wants left his neighbors a voicemail threatening to kill their entire family.
The father recognized Angelo's voice and knocked on his door to confront him to
Angela responded that he left a voicemail because that dog was barking too much.
His neighbors would often hear Joseph to Angelo screaming and cursing at his
wife and daughters so loudly that they could hear him inside the house.
He didn't seem to care what people thought of him because he frequently stood in
his front yard screaming at himself.
He would yell,
I'll kill you even though no one was there.
Meanwhile,
Sacramento County investigator Paul Holsten been hunting the golden state killer
for 24 years.
Holds was getting ready to retire,
but he was still obsessed with solving the case.
He was finally able to get a DNA ancestry company to agree to work with him and
uploaded the DNA from the golden state killer into an online database.
In January of 2018 through this technology,
he was able to find a third cousin holes.
Took this to a Sacramento County da and he assigned a task force to scour this
family tree.
Before this moment,
Joseph to Angelo had never been one of the potential suspects.
He had succeeded in hiding his crimes for 44 years.
The day before he was supposed to hand in his gun and badge.
Paul holes sat outside of Joseph James to Angelo's house.
At this point,
it was so jaded by the number of failed leads over the years that he didn't
actually expect to Angelo to be the one holds.
Wondered if he should just knock on the Angelou's door and ask for a DNA sample
so they could rule them out as a suspect,
but something in his gut told him to keep on driving DNA samples.
They take time to process and if he truly wants the golden state killer,
it would have too much time to run or possibly commit suicide.
The police followed Angelou in public places.
Instead,
they retrieved his DNA and fingerprints by wiping his car door and went through
his trash to find a discarded tissue.
The Sacramento Crime Lab and task force worked nonstop to connect the dots and
prove without a doubt that he was the golden state killer.
The police obtained a search warrant to go into Joseph Jane's to Angelo's home
and arrest Devon's [inaudible] Angela.
He was shocked police on the scene since they could see it in his eyes that he
was calculating a way to escape it,
but the officers detained him before he had a chance.
He didn't try to deny being the golden state killer.
He simply said,
there is a roast in the oven.
Since then,
he has not spoken a word to the police and refuses to give any interviews to
avoid incriminating himself.
Since then,
he just stares into space when he appears in court.
It's Angela.
His wife,
Sharon huddle,
moved away and stopped speaking 10 decades ago.
At the time of his arrest,
he was living with one of his adult daughters and his granddaughter.
His wife is a divorce lawyer and yet she never filed for divorce.
After being separated for so many years,
this has led some people to speculate to that he may have threatened her or that
she may know something about his crimes as his wife.
She will not be forced to testify against him in a court of law and this could
possibly save her from being partially responsible for his crimes.
Jaron huddle released a statement,
basically asking the press to leave her [inaudible].
My thoughts and prayers are for the victims and their families.
The press has relentlessly pursued interviews of me.
I will not be given any interviews for the foreseeable future.
I ask the press to please respect my privacy and that of my children according
to neighbors.
To Angela was physically fit as if he was only 50 years old.
Instead of 72 you had a stationary bike in the house,
rode a motorcycle,
and it was walking around without any issue.
However,
when his lawyers rolled up to the trial,
you were sitting in a wheelchair pretending to be a feeble old man who didn't
know what was going on.
This was his final attempt of self preservation,
but he wasn't fooling anyone during the motion hearings,
Angelo was no longer in a wheelchair.
He was standing inside of a bard holding cell next to an armed guard.
He started the judge the entire time with a blank expression.
You showed absolutely no emotion and no remorse.
It will be years before he goes to trial,
but not even his defense lawyer is trying to deny that he is the golden state
killer.
There is also an ongoing investigation with information that is being kept from
the public.
The police took a lot of his personal belongings from his home in to evidence,
which included many of them are menders that he stole from his victims.
It may be years before we learned any more details about his life or what drew
him to become the devil incarnate.
At the very least,
though,
Dangelo was finally behind bars.
Hopefully the victims and their families can finally get a good night's sleep.
So I really have found that video.
Interesting.
If you did,
please do give us a like below and don't forget to subscribe.
We've got videos like this.
Also more uplifting ones from people from history.
He went terribly evil.
Um,
so subscribe to that.
Find out more about those.
And like I said,
give us a like,
and as always,
thank you for watching.